Marc led which collected a ton of
interesting data about YouTube channels
and you might remember that one of the
discussions taking place in the sort of
YouTube sphere is the question of does
the right crush the left on YouTube I
did a livestream with secular talks Kyle
kolinsky about this about a year and a
half ago or so and there have been some
corporate media articles written that
make the claim that even on YouTube it's
not just on talk radio it's not on
whatever platform that even on YouTube
the political right is crushing the
political left and I want to go through
some of the interesting things that came
from the data compiled by mark LED which
and one really interesting aspect of
what he was able to uncover is which
channels recommend our content and which
channels are recommended by our videos
take a look at this and it important to
note that these estimates were done in a
sort of manual way this is not a fully
comprehensive analytics report but it's
still interesting so what this tells us
is which channels videos are we showing
up as recommendations for so if you're
watching for example Stephen Colbert how
frequently is YouTube's algorithm saying
if you like this video we're going to
recommend videos from for example the
David Pakman show
additionally which channels are
recommended to people watching our
videos so if you're watching a David
Pakman show YouTube clip how often is
the recommended clip a Sam cedar clip or
a Ring of Fire clip and interestingly we
received a ton of recommended video
views from Stephen Colbert followed by
Seth Meyers then The Young Turks CNN
MSNBC The New York Times secular talk
with Kyle kolinsky Trevor Noah's program
Bill Maher and NBC News that's on the
left side of this graphic on the right
side these are outbound recommendations
our YouTube channel recommended to
people sent viewers to The Young Turks
CNN MSNBC Sam cedar Stephen Colbert Fox
News the one right-wing media outlet
they're probably because we critique
them and the
algorithm is saying it seems like
related content bring a fire something
called tony's 24/7 eyes which i've never
heard of Seth Meyers and Trevor Noah
very very interesting sort of sphere of
influence on YouTube that we are sort of
in the middle of there there's another
interesting graphic which aggregates
left and right-wing views on YouTube and
left and right wing channels and what's
fascinating about this one and if you're
just listening to me describe this I
hope I'm doing an okay job what's
fascinating about this graphic is that
while there are way more right-wing
channels than left-wing channels in
terms of video views left-wing channels
actually significantly outdo not only
right-wing channels but left-wing
YouTube channels actually get more views
than right wing and centrist YouTube
channels combined so when we say the
left dominates the right or the right
dominates the left on YouTube there is
no question based on that data that
there are way more right-wing channels
on YouTube but the left-wing channels
are more successful in terms of the
audience that they bring what are the
takeaways from this in terms of what
needs to happen I have no idea I mean of
course I think there's a couple
different things going on one is that
corporate media and talk radio are so
overwhelmingly right wing and
corporatist that there may be a sort of
self selection where it's not that the
right can't succeed on a platform like
YouTube it's that there's more appetite
for alternatives to right-wing and sort
of corporatist centrist views and people
are finding a lot of those on YouTube so
I don't think that this tells us Pat you
know causation and correlation or two
different things we can't look at this
data and say this is because YouTube as
a platform inherently lends itself more
to left-wing views rather than
right-wing views because along the same
lines there's way more conspiracy
channels on YouTube than you see on talk
radio or corporate media that
simply because it's an open platform and
there is a sort of self selection bias
at play but for me the biggest takeaway
from this Pat was it's not true that the
right is crushing the left on YouTube
can you tell us at all that the david
pakman show has recently been crushing
it on YouTube getting several million
views a week maybe the most successful
we have been at least since the last
election or is that a different thing
altogether yeah I think we're gonna need
to Commission a custom study to
demonstrate that and that would be very
useful for me to do rants and raves
justifying people signing up for
membership but yeah I mean I love that
you're bringing that up but
unfortunately this stuff does not
particularly tell us that the the real
question that surface is from the data
is how does that YouTube algorithm
actually work we don't exactly know and
it's one of the most closely guarded
sort of trade secrets that YouTube has
in the same way that how the the Google
search algorithm works is a very closely
guarded secret that has so many factors
that impact it that it would be hard to
even sum up but very interesting data
from mark LED which and I really
appreciate him putting it together